so there's this big uh thing going on
now
in government called tick tock and and
uh
of course you and i have talked about
tick tock quite a bit brand in my house
right it's banned in your house but you
know i i think one of the things that
people don't understand is that the
problem with tick tock is really about
the
problem of what you can do today with
people's data so you can
literally understand
the personality the interactions the
relationships
nearly just about everything that you
want about a person
using the data collected by their
smartphone but then when you
build that into a smart city you
literally have
everything about the person now we
typically don't think about the problems
that causes but
as you and i have talked about the
ability to
influence you to buy a pair of shoes
that amazon leverages with their um
data empire and algorithms and and
machine learning and artificial
intelligence
can also be used to affect your
political orientation your
your cultural your social uh orientation
and really can be used as we know to
undermine
our our political system so you know
you know talk talk us through kind of
what the
data security problems are in 5g because
i think that's where um you know people
have heard this a faster smartphone but
okay
what's all that what's going who has
access to this data
that that you know the tech companies
are creating
yeah you're right that's a that's even a
you know a bigger picture description of
you know
what 5g does right is that 5g creates uh
you know
let's call it hypothetically 10x the
amount of data that we
we see today and even at a more at a
more granular level and if you believe
as as many do and i think china's even
come out and said this right
the data is the gold of the or the oil
of the next generation
then you gotta gotta scratch your head
and go in the u.s it's like well what
the hell are we doing about it right
we're
and so when you look at things like for
me when i look at things like tick tock
i'm like okay well why don't we just put
a
put a uh you know a beacon in
everybody's hand and let them walk
around and they can call in and collect
you know other nation states can collect
as much information as they want on on
individual us citizens or
or their surroundings as they need and
uh
and tick tock i think is just the poster
child for where
an explosive app or service can really
enable that that type of potential
you know government state sponsored you
know access to to u.s citizens which is
you know really unheard of because we
don't as american citizens we don't
really think about the
about the you know data and uh the
importance
you know of data but i think specific to
your question you know when you think
about 5g then you go okay well 5g
we've always also had this point of view
that that well
networks are secure because we trust our
our north american
you know wireless operators if we don't
trust them you know
who do we trust right and uh and the
reality is that historically
and you go uh you know through all the
g's up through 4g
it's primarily been driven by a lot of
uh us
influence or even directly by the u.s
where we've
always been leaders in the
telecommunications since the last
hundred years the us
has led the telecommunications industry
you look at it today and you go into 5g
we don't even have a telecommunications
manufacturer left in this country
so we're not leading anything so what
we're doing is buying other people's
products and services and putting it
into our networks
and then telling us citizens trust it's
okay
don't worry i bought it in china but you
can trust it so i mean
i think it's uh you know and that in and
of itself
exposes a lot of data risk you get into
all the issues whether it's you know
man in the middle and how people are
snooping on snooping on you
or you get into uh you know who owns
your data
right or you know do you trust your data
being you know unencrypted or
it raises a lot of questions and i think
there's a lot of data privacy issues
that come with 5g which we're just not
even really talking about because we
don't understand
that it's really about data and you know
let's
let's
win the battle for the oil of the next
generation
and let's let that drive our our
economic policy decisions and then also
drive what we should be doing
from a technology level as we build out
networks
you